la part de tous les québécois et
québécoises encore une fois au chômage
non reconnaissance à jacques parizeau
il a fait beaucoup pour la nation du
québec et il faudra continuer son oeuvre
une des raisons de mon engagement en
politique c'est d'avoir eu un entretien
avec monsieur parizeau il ya de cela
plusieurs années il a été certainement
plus qu'une source d'inspiration aussi
un exemple un exemple pour moi mais pour
un très grand nombre de québécois et de
québécoises qui croient en la capacité
des québécois de réussir il y avait sans
humour etc centenaire moi c'est se
souvenir que je garde de lui
j'ai un peu à l'envers je vous mets jeu
on a peur de mourir un objet mais c'est
un homme d'une grande civilité l homme
avec une grande intelligence et c'est un
homme qui nous a vraiment enrichi le
débat politique au québec
donc on le lui souvent aller dans les
universités faire des débats et sont
donc c'était quelqu'un qui était quand
même accessible y était y avait une
grande prestance mais c'est quand même
quelqu'un d'accessible pourquoi on
l'appelait monsieur mais parce qu'il
appelait tout le monde monsieur ou
madame ouattara lui il respectait les
gens alors les gens lui naturellement le
traité avec respect je regarde monsieur
parizeau
c'est peut-être la caractéristique sur
laquelle on a le moins cité cette
semaine c'était le côté très militant du
monsieur
moi je l' ai vu marie vrai c'est
complétera cravate là se rendre à des
campings de jeunes c'est très émouvant
on a perdu un grand homme qui s'est
battu pour nous pour le meilleur pour le
meilleur de nous en fait depuis qu'il
nous a quittés je pense que c'est le
sentiment qu'on ressent toute cette
passion qu'ils incluent pour le québec
qu'il incarne et on va essayer de
l'apprendre à poursuivre la politique
c'est souvent malmenés
comme métier et monsieur parizeau a su
donner de la hauteur à la politique par
sa rigueur par son respect et toute la
dignité qui la portait